welcome back to las vegas now well
change is a good thing right and the
sponsors of this next segment chapman
automotive have some big changes on the
horizon here to tell us more is don
hamrick the president of nevada
operations thank you so much for being
here great to be here julian you're
always hanging out with everyone and now
i get the chance to talk with you
this is going to be fun all right you
guys have a lot of exciting things on
the horizon here tell us what we can
look forward to so many great things
happening our company has gone through
some great transitions we are remodeling
our store that was on boulder highway
since the mid 1960s and when i say
remodeling i actually mean we took it to
the ground and rebuilt it complete 70
000 square foot dealership there's a
nice picture to give you an idea and
it's going to be really designed to
offer our employees a great place to
come to work and our customers a super
place to do business so we open that
middle of june so we are less than a
month away and my people are so excited
wow well congratulations on that we
can't wait to see it and tell us a
little bit about this collision center
you know that's enough so we're going to
brand new collision centers well what we
discovered was having a collision center
with our dealership really didn't work
well for either of them so we needed
that space so the collision center could
have its own area we bought a property
just up the street less than a mile away
built it into one of the nicest
collision centers when you walk inside
you can't believe it's that type of
facility but it's quite extraordinary
all self-enclosed so heated and cooled
for our technicians to work in comfort
in these las vegas summers 110 degrees
they're going to be inside chill and
they'll going to do great work for us
there so that opened about a month ago
already through tremendous excitement
from our customers as well wow that is
really great and another thing that's
great not one year not two years but for
the third year in a row you just
received a special award tell us about
that
so it's pretty exciting so the walter p
chrysler award is given to
dealerships that really attain a certain
level of performance not only in their
sales their service employee
satisfaction customer satisfaction your
parts your your business office they
look at every aspect of your business it
is so stringent and so difficult that
last year only 30 dealers out of 30 out
of 3 000 earned the award wow 30 out of
3 000 we were one of those and it's our
third year in a row so it's something
i'm tremendously proud of really for our
team they're the ones doing the work i
just get to to come talk to you but
they're the ones doing the hard work and
dealing with our customers every day and
making sure that we meet those
objectives well a lot of exciting things
coming up change is good but the one
thing that you always say doesn't change
you guys are still the number one
dealership here in vegas right and you
know it's it's nice and i think it's
really more a reflection of the effort
that we put in with our clients and our
customers are happy and our employees
are happy so we're number one for three
years in a row i fully expect that to
continue with all that we're doing and
the big investment we're making in the
community so let's cross our fingers and
hope for the best crossing our fingers
congratulations dawn thank you so much
for being here give chapman dodge
chrysler jeep ram a call at 702
457
or visit las vegas dodge dot com and
remember their special offer zero
percent financing for 72 months